tu es magnifique un autisme neuf ans de
mariage signifie comme toi bronson et
jennings le groupe pharmaceutique
il cote à 25 lundi prochain ils vendent
à moitié moi je t'écoute vas-y raconte
moi tout
tu peux me dire ce qui se passe c'est à
cause de warda de toute façon on est
innocent or vous n'étiez manifestement
pas au courant de ses activités
j'entends donc la requête de la défense
et vous infliger une peine de 100 heures
de travaux d'intérêt général effective
sur le champ bienvenue au centre pour
aveugles pour les déficients visuels
le toucher c'est la vue donc ne soyez
pas gêner s'il vous touche
sézanne date human je ne veux pas être
facile à porter comme nous en ce moment
c'est mon grille je suis sûr qu'il va
être sympathique quand vous le connaître
là encore qu'avait-il dans ce nord une
minute attendez on sait le passage le
plus important du livre c'est à ce
moment qu'on se rend compte qu'elle ne
peut pas continuer soit on décide de
changer radicalement de vie ce qui peut
être pas simplement effrayant car passe
le reste de ses jours étouffé dans un
cocon rassurant mais la nuit on rêve de
plaisir
paul fleury la dernière fois avec une
femme rien depuis ma femme vous devait
dîner avec moi ce soir et je vous
emmènerai à paris
est ce que je peux vous
qu'est-ce que
vous avez 2
vos courriers
voire plus je vois que vous êtes très
belle je veux voir comme vous voyez
qu'est ce que je dois faire pour
préserver la seule chose intacte hector
qui me reste dans la vie il fut d'abord
submerger par son parfum et les noeuds
puis plonger la tête la première dans
son temple sacré 9 riez plus jamais
suzanne
je ne sais plus à quoi ressemble votre
religion
wihr ste plein tout le monde des erreurs
quand on passe par là suzanne on rêve de
plaisir qu'on n'aura jamais effleuré et
d'amour qu'on leur a échappé en tête
[Musique]
falloir que ça change